why don't we go to nick from tennessee
next nick you're on the air
nick from tennessee you're on the air
hey david can you hear me yes i can
hey uh thanks for taking my call my
question is actually
about the stock market um it's something
that i've taken
interest in um mainly after
reading matt tybee's journalistic work
on the
2008 financial crisis and
learning more through the documentary
capital in the 21st century
and my question for you is um is it
am i overestimating the impact that
the stock market and financial market
has on our
system or is it something that doesn't
get talked about due to the sort of
inaccessibility of it and
how hard it is to enact change um
well you might have to say a bit no i i
think um
i think many people accurately
understand the impact
of the financial system the stock market
being a piece of that
on our political system um you you know
maybe you could be more specific in
terms of the ways you think are not
appreciated enough but i think anybody
who's paying attention to the political
space in a serious way understands
that the financial system is
inextricably linked to the political
system both in terms of how the
financial system
funds the political system but also how
it has created sort of this revolving
door
of regulatory capture where you have
the regulators and the industry leaders
and the elected officials all
together and often going from one role
to the next
is there a specific way you think it's
underappreciated
i it's tough because i'm just learning
about it so i'm i'm still sort of
finding the excuse me the vocabulary to
um
to express you know my concern with it
but yeah
in learning just the history of um
how the stock market essentially took
over the economy
um as soon as it was introduced or
created
in you know around the time just after
industrialization in america and the
fact that it has sort of remained this
very powerful presence but doesn't seem
to ever
enter the uh the political arena of
discussion
at least on on the level of public
discourse which we hear
from most media sources yeah i think i
think to some degree you're
right i mean i do think that there's a
superficial analysis of if the stock
market's up it signals a good economy
and if it's down it signals a bad
economy and of course the stock market
isn't the economy
and stocks are disproportionately held
by a relatively small
percentage of people certainly the vast
vast majority of the shares
uh but i i think i would agree with you
that there's not a deeper analysis of
the connection between the stock market
and and the political system that that
maybe you would be useful but i do think
most people are at least generally aware
of the role of the stock market and how
publicly traded companies
generally speaking operate
that's fair and um like i said i'm still
learning and
and new to this world but it's just
something that has really intrigued me
lately
um and just one final question for you
and i've
learned through watching your content
that you participate
in the stock market um what is your
i guess stance on it as a participant um
from our you know the ground level of
being just a consumer who is also
involved in stocks and investing yeah so
this isn't financial advice
advice but as i've said before uh you
know my
my full-time thing is not picking stocks
and making investments
and even the people who do that
full-time often
underperform the market averages so i'm
not
arrogant enough to think i'm
particularly good at picking stocks
so my approach is dollar cost averaging
regularly buying
more and more shares of low cost index
funds
which you can get for you know sometimes
five basis points meaning 0.05 percent
fees nope
not paying any managers one one and a
half percent
fees for for managing a hedge fund just
go with the lowest
price index funds and then within my
portfolio maybe
three to five percent of my money is in
individual stocks that i have some
knowledge of so for example people know
i bought tesla stock six years ago
and i have a few other individual stocks
but my approach as a participant is
i'm busy hosting my show running a
business i devote
very little time to picking stocks and
i'm just buying the broader
index funds and paying as little as
possible in fees
cool uh thanks a lot for taking my call
i really enjoy your show
and i look forward to more all right my
pleasure nick from tennessee great to
hear from you